when the chief rabbi of Israel put a ban
that Jews cannot marry more than one
woman.
Then 1950
just 74 years back
when we read the statement of status of
women in Islam
published in 1975 page number 66 and 67
it says that the percentage of
polygamous marriages in India
Muslims had 4.31%
polygamous marriage 4.31
in a span of 1951 to 1961 in a span of
10 years. This report is saying in a
span of 10 years 1951 to 1961 then the
Muslims had 4.31%
of polygamous marriages and the Hindus
had 5.06 06
that means
7.75%
the Hindus did more polygamous marriages
than the Muslims though in India the
Muslim is allowed to have more than one
wife by law
Muslim personal act
but the Hindu from 1954 it's illegal for
them to have more than one wife yet even
though it's illegal more Hindus
do polygamous mis marriages in India
than Muslims. Imagine if the law allowed
how they done how many.
So these are statistics.
Now let us understand what does Quran
what does Islam say.
Allah says in the Quran in surah nisa
chapter 4 verse number three
marry woman of your choice in twos
threes or fours but if you can't do
justice marry only one so this statement
that marry only one is only in the Quran
I'm repeating Allah says in the Quran in
surah nisa chapter 4 verse number three
marry woman of your choice in twos
threes or fours but And if you can't do
justice, marry only one. This statement,
if you can't do justice, marry only one,
is only given in the Quran. And Allah
further says inah chapter 4 verse number
129, you cannot be just
between, you cannot do justice between
the women altogether.
You cannot do complete justice between
the women. BUT DO NOT TURN AWAY from
them altogether.
That means Allah is telling in the Quran
few verses later in chapter 429 you
cannot be totally just between the women
but do not turn away from them. Do not
neglect them altogether. That means in
Islam marrying more than one wife is not
fur. Many people think it's compulsory.
In Islam it is optional. There are five
rulings in Islam. Further is compulsory
must or sunnah which is preferable
encouraged. Number three is optional
mubah. Number four is makru which is
discouraged and number five is haram
prohibited. So marrying more than one
wife for a man it's optional.
But in India they say
mean we two have two children you five
have 25 children
that means you know husband wife marry
they have two children the Muslim they
marry four wives and they have 25
children that's how the population is
increasing
they fail to realize logically and
technically Ally there is an error. If
one man marries one woman and if one man
marries four women.
If there are four women each one, one
man marrying each woman and if one man
marries four, the chances of procreation
is more if four women have one one
husband as compared to one man having
four wives scientifically
because he'll have more chances etc. So
it is a misconception to say
we two we have two children you five
have 25. It's an illogical
[clears throat]
argument.